[Applause]
she molded me what an experience
the africans don't be out there [ __ ]
with the lions they ask them mr matumbo
why you don't play with the lion i'm not
[ __ ] with that [ __ ]
[ __ ] him and [ __ ] you that [ __ ] is not
in the brochure i'm not doing that [ __ ]
when my shift is over i want to go home
to my children mangulu mungala and
i can't do it [ __ ] with that when the
[ __ ] around you better come i will leave
you in the car
is rules
ain't no african people here is it are
you african dog my bad
i want to piss you off and you
[ __ ]
you know what's [ __ ] up african people
don't like black people
y'all know they treat us like [ __ ] they
talk down to us they think they're
better than us
and i don't understand because we're
from the same tribe
kind of but they like white people
though they treat y'all like family
as soon as y'all come around they get
excited excuse me mr white man
thank you for bringing us here we love
you
yeah dwight mommy
[Applause]
as soon as they see us they get attitude
hey how you doing this
[ __ ] we don't like the black man in
america [ __ ] you don't work you
don't do [ __ ]
we don't like you you black [ __ ]
like who are you calling black
[ __ ] i'm brown you midnight who
the [ __ ] are you calling black
like [ __ ] if you stood up against the
building you'd look like an alley who
the [ __ ] are you going
the [ __ ] is unjust
african men don't understand why when
they come to america they have a hard
time getting american [ __ ]
you can't be that aggressive with
american women especially black women
you got to know how to talk you got to
come correct mama's in africa is used to
having a way they got 15 wives and [ __ ]
and african women are very obedient they
tell a woman what to do it's not even
the issue
[ __ ] when they come home you
i don't know why they do that dude
you better you about to clean this [ __ ]
from the floor i don't
maybe in the club stalking women out
here you can't even see them they be as
black as my jacket
you just see the yellow of their eyes
from a distance looking like congo in
the bush
as soon as you go by your drink they
jump out the shadows and scare the [ __ ]
at you [ __ ] what is your name
come here don't run from me
white people when y'all get mad at us
please stop saying this [ __ ]
why don't you go back to africa
what how the [ __ ] we gonna go back to
some [ __ ] we ain't never been to
y'all act like we're born with maps of
that [ __ ] our head
like we'll just land over there take me
to shambuku's house
now go down three elephants make a left
of the line
the [ __ ] over there he over there
we don't ask y'all to go back to england
you ain't from this [ __ ] either
yeah so why don't you go to bloody
england
dawn and go pop sucker
i ain't going back to africa
because some of them africans do not
like us
black americans they can't stand us from
the east coast you know what i'm talking
about
i was in dc on tour right first time i
went there
you know saying i wanted to go out and
see the city so i jump in the cab cause
you know [ __ ] was broke at the time
what no tv show or limo [ __ ] it was
taxa
so i wanted to go see the white house
the capitol and internal revenue service
building
just in case they over taxi [ __ ] i know
what building to blow the [ __ ] up
so i'm in the cab the [ __ ] cab
driver had the audacity
to turn around and say you're not too
rich you know black man
you want to run that by me again bro i
say you're not the rich and the black
man i said how black i gotta be
[ __ ]
just cause you one of the [ __ ] that
got away
cause white people when y'all ancestors
came to pick us up y'all wasn't looking
for a little bony brother y'all was
looking for
big cotton picking [ __ ] and
them little bony ones over in africa set
us up
you don't want me
look at me coffee at a time got one nut
shambuku over there big and strong
we seen him pick up a whole orchid by
himself
i help you catch them i'm sitting in the
back getting mad to [ __ ] i said
who winning in this situation
[ __ ] you driving me to the white
house
when he pulled in front in the white
house he looked in the back seat all he
seen was an open door
i was gone didn't pay for
[ __ ] yell back at the cab now go back to
africa and tell them how
[ __ ] done your ass wrong
you uppity [ __ ]
and this is what we need to do we need
to get out there and say
this is how it works educate them okay
so let's do this then so it's just with
the seeds you're not giving her
and so i'm a starving african hello carl
you got any food
got any got any food got any sandwiches
well stuff
but if i give you my sandwich there's
someone else behind you and they'll all
come out so what do you do then what are
you going to do
i'm going to help you how what can i do
i'm going to i'm going to make you think
about how to make food
okay right have you ever grown anything
before no no
right well there's some seeds for
potatoes oh thanks carl see you later
don't just put them in the ground yeah
put it in the ground water them oh
there's no water you don't you can't
there is some no there's no water dopey
that's why we're starving today we can't
right well
at that point that's where we go well
this is a lost cause eh right there's no
point
after all no you're not having it so not
only can i have a sandwich you give me
seeds with no water you useless
bald-headed [ __ ] twunk
right but there's gotta be another way
around this go on then either move
right because every year they're going
to be queuing up saying i'm going to
give me a sandwich
no you're not having another sandwich
once again it's an utterly ill-informed
discussion
we've got the best politicians in the
world out here you know we don't
appreciate that they've got the flair
man
they've got that whole vibe i love it i
love it
and i think sometimes we are a bit hard
on them you know based on how they speak
which is which is sometimes not fair you
know i mean we
we do give it to them a bit like i mean
julius at the end of the day he says
stupid things but then you get people
that judge our politicians because of
how they sound you know
forgetting that at the end of the day
there is such a thing as a black accent
we seem to have forgotten that you know
so now the black accents has
automatically been associated with
stupidity and shouldn't be the case
because there's french accents you know
there's indian accents the chinese
accents
and then there should be a black accent
you know that's the way it should be
yeah
but we forget that we forget that it
just gets associated with that you know
people try and change it you get people
changing it all the time how people
pronounce things when a french person
says it it's sexy it has that gene
they can say anything you know they can
be like i've been really impressed with
their
with the other management of the company
he'll be like oh wow oh wow take me now
jean-pierre take me now
well then a black guy will say the same
thing and we'll judge them i i've been
very impressed uh
with the management of the
the [ __ ] the company itself and we'll be
like
no no no no
taboo it's not
management it's management
yeah management
management no no management
management close management
management well done well done jabu now
you're saying it properly well done you
see
at this rate hold on what's that sarah
oh so they won the election
oh by majority so the country's theirs
now
okay thank you sarah thank you jabu
management
now teach me teach me
[Applause]
i wish i never traveled forever real
cause i could i would like just
never had travel outside this country
and then i could hate america
and be happy you know what i'm saying
but i traveled
and now it's like now i like america but
i still hate it's weird i hate it but
it's nowhere better because all i got to
really deal with is racist crackers like
that and that's
that's it's funny because like i don't
black people really don't look at white
people with
like you're the oppressor anymore it's
just something we do it's just like we
like
not liking white people and white people
like not liking us it's like it's just
that's just what we do it's just
because i'm not going nowhere and i'll
kill a [ __ ] he told me to go
like back to africa listen i'm talking
to black people stop that
[ __ ] horseshit that go back to
africa [ __ ] first of all africans
don't like black people that's first one
they don't like us and what the [ __ ] am
i gonna do
in africa
besides fighting some war wearing uh
sweatpants and tuxedo shoes
with a [ __ ]
with a [ __ ] machete in my hand with a
pair of [ __ ] tuxedo shoes
and a knife fighting some goofy ass
[ __ ] wall [ __ ] it